location is crucial for a thriving
vegetable garden most vegetables need at
least 6 to 8 hours of direct sunlight
daily ensure your garden gets plenty of
sunlight and has well- draining soil
healthy soil is the foundation of a
successful vegetable garden test your
soil's pH and nutrient levels add
compost or well- rotted manure to
improve soil structure and fertility
consider no till gardening to preserve
soil Health selecting the right
vegetables depends on your climate soil
and preferences choose vegetables suited
to your local climate and space start
with easy to grow vegetables like
lettuce radishes and beans if you're a
beginner the quality of your seeds or
seedlings can significantly impact your
garden success choose highquality
disease resistant varieties start seeds
indoors before the last frost date or
purchase healthy seedlings from a local
Nursery proper watering is essential for
healthy vegetable plants keep the soil
consistently moist but not water logged
water the base of the plants early in
the morning to reduce evaporation and
prevent disease crop rotation is crucial
for maintaining soil health and
preventing pests and diseases rotate
vegetable families each year to reduce
the risk of soil born diseases and
maintain soil fertility hey everyone if
you enjoyed this video make sure to hit
that like button and subscribe to our
channel for more awesome content don't
forget to click the Bell icon so you
never miss an update thanks for watching
and see you next time